This video is brought to you by Blinkus the first 100 people to go to
blinkist.com forward slash biographics. So you're at a week to try it out.
You'll also get 25% off if you want the full membership,
which you probably will, and let's get into it.
The 1977,
a 47 year old former wall street analyst made California history.
Harvey milk was the first openly gay man to be elected to public office in the
sunshine state.
And one of the first in the entire United States at a time when public workers
were still being fired for homosexuality milk showed that you could be not just,
but openly defiantly, radically, and still win votes.
It was an iconic moments in both gay history and American history in general,
sadly,
it was shortly followed by another moment that was iconic for all the wrong
reasons. Almost exactly a year after winning election milk was assassinated,
gunned down in his office by a former colleague.
But while everyone knows the story of Harvey milk,
San Francisco icon and gay martyr, how much do they know about Harvey?
Milk's a man born into a Jewish family in 1930.
Milk grew up at a time of virulent homophobia.
Initially hiding behind a tough guy act.
He finally grew to accept who he was only to discover that this openness had
tragic consequences, a complex sometimes troubled figure.
This is the story of Harvey milk as a man who became the mater.
Yeah.
When Harvey milk was born on the 22nd of May, 1930,
it was into a time and place that didn't want him to even exist.
The part of long islands,
his Jewish parents lived in had recently been a stronghold of the KKK and
antisemitism was still just an accepted fact of life.
Although the milks were able to run a department store and go to synagogue.
Harvey would spend his school years excluded by the local rich kids for his
Jewishness.
And while milk's religion certainly made him a target for the chronically
ignorance. It had nothing on his sexuality from an early age.
Harvey milk was deeply aware that he was gay for a respectable family.
In the 1930s. This was a major no-no milk's father.
William seems to have been suspicious of his son and constantly berated him,
trying to force him to man up and act straight milk soon learned to do
as his father demanded the boy wasn't stupid.
He'd seen what happens to the feminine kids at school. That's uh,
to just go with the flow, to be the man his father wanted him to be.
This has meant assuming the role of a teenage jock, immense of playing football,
baseball, and hanging out with pretty girls butts.
A roll was all it ever was a mask that Harvey tried to tell the world was his
real face inside though. He was in turmoil at that time.
Harvey's parents lived near a road leading to the ferry to fire Island.
They notorious gay pickup spot.
Teenage Harvey would see gay men returning at night and watch them from his
bedroom window desperately wishing that he could join them.
But the narrow pane of glass separating them may as well have been a concrete
wall. At some point, the confused milk went to see the family rabbi.
When they were alone, the boy broke down and confessed to homosexuality.
The rabbis reply with something milkweed. Remember until the day he died,
you shouldn't be concerned about how you live your life. The rabbi said,
as long as you feel you're living it right, even now,
this would be a progressive statement in the 1940s.
It was like the rabbi blasting out. Donna Summers,
I feel love while wearing a rainbow flag comforting as these words were they,
they definitely weren't mainstream opinion. In the summer of 1947,
the teenage milk visited a cruising spot for the first time,
going to parts of central park, where he knew gay men like to hang out,
barely had he arrived before he was arrested and taken into custody for the 17
year old, the experience was a living nightmare. He begs the officers,
told them he was just a high school kid going for a walk that had made a
mistake. Eventually they let him go. But the experience Scott milk,
it learns the hard way exactly what sort of world he lived in a world,
which considered being gay to be a crime.
Now firmly back in the closet, no can roles.
It's the New York state college for teachers there.
He studied maths and languages while working as a sports editor of the local
paper, but he also found time to make a trip that would change his life.
And the winter of 1950 Harvey milk took a vacation in Cuba.
This was Cuba before the revolution, before the military government of Battista,
it was a free and open society for the 20 year olds milk.
It was a revelation when he returned to the U S he stops writing about sports.
He began writing instead about civil rights.
It was the first step on the journey from Harvey milk,
that closeted gay men to Harvey milk the radical activist,
but make no mistake. We're still a very long way to go.
[Inaudible].
In 1951,
Harvey left the teacher's college drift and directionless had originally hoped
to continue his studies in German,
but had flunked so badly that no language school would ever accept such a total
dumb cough. Seeing his rudderless son William milk,
decided to push the boy into doing something.
Matt show something that would definitely whip the sissy out of him.
He sends the milk off to join the Navy.
If you've ever seen that Simpsons episode where Homer accidentally takes bar to
a gay steel mill, just know this wasn't his real life equivalent.
That is based in San Diego,
milkman other gay men for the first time in his life.
When he went out to drink in town,
he discovered that his crisp uniform was an absolute dude, magnets,
but we wouldn't want to suggest milk's Naval.
Life was just one big coming out party.
He wound up serving in the Korean war as a driving instructor on board,
the USS Kidd or Walker, although he never saw action. He still nested himself.
Some metals milk's life. As a sailor ended on February the seventh, 1955,
he received an honorable discharge, not the dishonorable. One had laid to claim.
He got for being gay and found himself once again, back in civilian life.
And once again, rudderless, rather than go back to his parents,
he moved to Los Angeles. It was out West.
That milk connects two important people. The first was Susan Davis,
a young Jewish girl who took to calling herself milk's hack.
The second was Davis's other gay friends, John Holly, handsome and headstrong.
John swept, Harvey milk, clean off his feet.
Milk adored the man calling him a God. The two moved in together. First in LA,
is that in Miami becoming partners with a speed that left milk dizzy.
John was his first serious boyfriend. The first time he'd been in love,
naturally milks thought it would last forever.
But when does first love have a lost in early 1956 after belly a year
together, John walked out of Harvey milk's life,
leaving him alone in Miami at first milk, trying to make the best of it.
He briefly haunted the gay bars of powder puff lane,
but he soon got arrested and was charged with perversion on Israelis,
say depressed stands, disillusioned milk returns along islands.
The next few years passed in an aimless blur back home milk briefly worked as a
teacher before meeting his second boyfriends. The 19 year olds, Joe Campbell,
the two trying to fall into first start in Dallas,
but Merrill felt they didn't like his Jewishness down in Texas.
So the pair returned to New York,
although their partnership would last for four years.
Most of those were unhappy. Milk was simply too angry,
too prone to treating the younger man like a wastrel son instead of a lover.
As the years passed, Joe started seeing other men secretly at first,
then almost openly for as part Harvey made a frankly embarrassing attempts to.
So do you see Susan Davis finally in 1961,
Joe officially kills the lifeless marriage.
He moved out of Harvey's apartment vanishing from his life only now realizing
what had lost milk wrote stacks of love letters, begging him to come back.
And Joe just ignored them all in the wake of the breakup milk tried returning to
Miami only to find himself back. Once again, in New York, his 1963 dawned,
still feeling lost by now.
He was 33 and nobody with no Korea and there's nothing behind him,
but two failed relationships. However, all of that was about to change milk.
Couldn't have known it yet,
but he was just 12 short months away from a meeting that would transform his
life.
[Inaudible].
1964, felons milk at lost on sound financial footing.
Now working on wall street as a securities research analyst,
he was making good money for the first time in his life.
It was also getting seriously into conservative politics. Yep.
Conservative politics. If you're a mental image of Harvey milk is some lefty.
San Francisco liberal.
You should know that he campaigns for Barry Goldwater at the 1964 election,
always a supporter of free enterprise.
Milk's homosexuality also made him deeply suspicious of government intrusion to
him. The Republican party just seems like the natural fit,
but while milk was leaning rightward, politically,
he was also dating men who moved in very different.
The first of these was Craig Rodwell, millions of activists. Now today,
if according to the term gay power,
although their relationship was briefings ended with Naga dumping Rodwell for
giving him the clap.
It exposed milk to a whole new world of gay activism as well.
1960s milk would claim to be uninterested in Rockwell's campaigning.
1970s milk would have no problem stealing his tactics.
The second more consequential relationship milk formed was with Jack Galen
McKinley. A pretty young thing of only 17.
Galen was dating the 40 year old Tom Horgen. When milk LeWitt in my wave,
this was something of a recurring theme in milk's relationships.
The just legal boy,
he could act as both a lover and a father figure to the Horgan seems to have
cared about to being replaced. And Galen's affections.
The off-Broadway director took a shine to Galen's new leather and he and milks
soon became friends.
The creative scene that surrounded the director was a natural fit for milk.
While Galen worked on the technical side of our Horgan's plays,
milk was given bit roles.
The thrill of performance suited his flamboyant personality.
He even managed to Pele his acting career and do a bit part in a film directed
by Robert Downey, Sr that's right. Same dude. Harvey milk,
totally hung around with iron man's dad.
How's that for an Avenger stall across I,
that the longer milk stayed with Galen,
the more he began to abandon his wall street image,
he started wearing his hair long, began attending anti-Vietnam war protests.
Finally, in the summer of 1969, he did what all hippies do.
He moved to San Francisco. The catalyst was the production of Heather's.
A Horgan was directing in the city and which Gaylen was part of the crucial
organ, invited milk along.
And he accepted abandoning his well-paid job for a life of creativity and flower
power. At least that was the plan.
The reality was that there was no paid role for knock on has.
So we wound up cutting off his ponytail and taking a well-paid job in San
Francisco at an investment bank.
It wasn't quite the summer of love that milk was expecting still.
The important point is that this was it.
The moments that Harvey milk laid eyes on San Francisco,
and it was love at first sight in the city's volume, brick,
Gacy milk found something that had been missing in New York.
There was something about how people in San Fran were just so in your face.
So unapologetic, he may have rejected rod Wells,
gay militancy while they were dating,
but now Harvey milk was wholeheartedly embracing activism,
but it was only a brief of fad that milk had with the city that, yeah,
just a quick fling. In spring of 1970,
he got fired from his new job for attending an anti-Wall rally with Oregon
heading back to New York. He decided to, again, tag along,
but this was not the end of Harvey milk and San Francisco's relationship.
Even as he headed East milk, knew that he would be coming back.
When he finally did, he was going to transform this city.
If you're looking to transform yourself a great way to do that can be with
knowledge. And that brings me to today's sponsor link guest. Now, look,
it's not always easy to find the time to sit down and read all the books he
wants or even listen to the audio book versions, because those can be pretty.
I'm a busy dude. I understand that.
I don't read nearly as much as I used to nearly as much as I would like to,
but good news. I've got Blinkus. This is an app that you can download.
And then on,
there is 15 minutes summaries of all the best non-fiction books they've got over
3000 of them in there. May I, uh,
I tend to listen to the summaries most of the time,
although sometimes I'll dive into the ends of the, uh, into the return section,
but I just find 50 minutes. It's pretty great for, you know,
listening to on the commute to work or while I'm doing some mindless things
around the house, they're all 12 million active users on Blinkist, by the way,
getting the best insights and need to know information from thousands of books,
business to health. Self-help, whatever you're into.
It's all along that they've also got these great curated lists where the
Blinkist team have gone through and they've put together specific
recommendations. Uh,
some of these like how to future-proof yourself and there's other ones just kind
of staff favorite, stuff like that. And of course you can download,
listen offline. What have I been, I've been going through, I've got facts,
wellness here. I actually finished that one already. Um, uh,
the snowball Warren Buffett's book. I mean not his book,
but about Warren buffet, total recall bomb resource nugget,
his biography autobiography. That's a great one. Anyway,
the first a hundred people to go to blinkist.com forward slash biographics got a
week to try it out. 25% off. If you're on the full membership again,
seven day cancel at anytime trial,
blinkist.com forward slash biographics and let's return to today's video.
Holding milk Fest.
Old friends. He plans to become mayor of San Francisco as early as November,
1969.
But it wasn't until 1972 that he actually did anything about it that year.
He moved back to the city with his new boyfriend's Joseph Scott Smith,
who had met on the New York subway on his 41st birthday.
Bankwest milk initially planned to open a Jewish deli,
but he couldn't get the funds together.
And instead settled on a camera shop located on Castro street.
The shop was right in front of the beating heart of San Francisco's growing gay
community.
And it was exactly where Milt wanted to be as a now openly gay man with a
friendly theatrical personality, running a store in the middle of the gay scene.
Milk naturally became a local icon.
There's some evidence that this was his plan all along and before his store,
it even been open a year milk who was filing to run in the 1973 election for the
city's board of supervisors.
But if bell could expect it to instantly reach high office,
it was doomed to disappointments. The local Democrat party turned him down,
memorably telling him you don't get to dance unless you put up the chairs and
I've never seen you put up the chairs.
The more established gay activists also refuse to work with him.
Seeing milk is some New York loud mouth trying to muscle in on that tough,
still milk. Wasn't a tenant. He gamely ran regardless,
trying to pull together an Alliance of marginalized groups,
trying to touch on issues that affected not only LGBT people,
but also Hispanics, the black community, the working class and senior citizens,
while it enough to get him elected.
It was enough to place him at respectable 10th out of 32,
but it was away from the ballot box.
That milk would first spread his political wings. That same year, 1973,
the team's disunion was organizing a boycott of cause bear after the firm hard
non-union labor milk approached them with a proposition.
He would convince gay bars across San Francisco to stop stocking because in
return, all the teams decided to do was agreed to hire gay drivers. By now,
San Francisco is probably the gayest city in America with one estimate claiming
nearly a fifth of the voting age population was LGBT.
So when milk came good on its promise as quickly caved,
it was milk's first major political victory,
even though he had lost the election,
it still proved that activists and macro blue collar unions could work
together. This insight would become the basis for his future success.
After the cause boycott milk,
essentially it became a full-time activist in 1974,
he created the Castro village association,
the first organization in America to consist predominantly of LGBT owned
businesses. As his president's milk started preaching a message of gay.
Self-sufficiency telling other gay men to only shop in stores owned by people,
or at least straight people who supported gay rights.
His message made him notorious enough that he was able to run for supervisor
again in 1975, but he was not notorious enough to win.
Although Harvey managed to triple his vote,
he still finished a damning seventh out of seven,
but the campaign alone turned out to be enough that same year liberal style
Wars. George Moscone was elected mayor of San Francisco.
The former majority leader of the California Senate Moscone had been famously
progressive advocating lower sentences for smoking pots and pushing to repeal
California's sodomy laws as San Francisco's new mayor.
He was determined to build an administration that actually resembled the city
one in which minority voices would be heard.
One of the voices was Harvey milk's in early 1976,
mayor Moscone appointed milk to the board of permit appeals milk became the
first openly gay city commissioner in America, a major statements from Moscone,
but milk wasn't content to merely be appointed to his post.
He wanted to show that people didn't need straight allies to get ahead that they
were capable of winning elections themselves. So not long after that Moscone,
heart and milk resigned with the intention of running for office. Again,
this time he would finally win.
[Inaudible].
Two years past in a blur of politics in 1976,
milk ran for the California state assembly only to see the pressure of running
yet. Another political campaign destroying his relationship with Scott Smith.
So milk changed tack and instead founded the San Francisco gay democratic
club.
The clubs successfully challenged the way the board of supervisors was elected
resulting in bothered one, spin, citywide, voting,
being ditched for votes by districts.
And one of those new districts just happened to be centered around milks power
base and Castro street.
The outcome of this change was inevitable in 1977,
a coalition of LGBT people and blue collar union workers,
propels milk to victory in the latest board of supervisors election.
It was a major progressive wave yet alongside milk.
The city also elected its first Chinese American supervisor and first female
African-American supervisor still. It was milk that the press focused on,
although he wasn't the first out person to be elected to public office in the
USA that honor went to Kathy Kazak Chenko in 1970,
he was the first who seemed to be spearheading a movement milk.
Wasn't just a politician who happened to be gay.
He was a politician loudly declaring that he was gay and that gay rights would
be part of his agenda at his swearing in ceremony. For example,
milkmaid a speech condemning bans on gay marriage,
but while he was great for the American LGBT community to see one of them
members finally vocally standard,
don't go thinking that everything was hunky Dory for America.
At that same sentiment,
another supervisor was sworn in whose views with a polar opposite of Harvey.
Milk's Dan white was a Vietnam vet and former policemen who'd run for office
because he felt the rising tide of social liberalism was drowning. His city.
He felt that pot smokers and homos were turn San Francisco into a pink
paradise and Harvey milk. He would find the homo. He hated yeah.
More than any other, but down wide.
It was likely the last thing on milk's mind in early 1978,
by now he was receiving death threats almost daily,
and I'd even recorded a tape marks in events of my assassination.
His friends teased him about it. Austin, who do you think you are? Gay?
Malcolm X, sadly.
These joke comments would turn out to be painfully prescient from the get-go
milk's role. As a supervisor was a baptism of fire.
He had a groundbreaking initiatives, including fronting.
What was then the strongest anti LGBT discrimination bill in us history.
The only supervisor who refused to vote in favor of it was Dan white,
but even as milk cheered, his first policy victory,
a bigger battle was already brewing the year before the singer needs a brand
that successfully fronted a campaign to appeal gay rights in Florida.
This had sparked a wave of anti-gay legislation across the U S his newly
acquired rights were suddenly snatched away.
Now it was California's turn proposed in the state Senate by John Briggs
proposition six was one of the ugliest bills of the Arab and attempts to not
just make it mandatory to fire gay teachers, but to fire.
Any teacher who held any non negative views about homosexuality,
the scariest part was that voters seem to love it. In August.
That year polls showed 61% of California's electorate supported prop six.
It was a warning shot across the bow of the gay community. Yeah.
Signal to not get all appetite,
just because you got one elected in San Francisco. When milk heard of prop six,
he was horrified.
It seems like even the sunshine stage was desperate to turn back the clock to
the misery of the 1930s.
So he vows to do what he did best Harvey milk was going to fight fire
with fire.
Okay.
In the film milk,
one pump that probably stuck with you is the scene where Harvey milk takes
apart. The utterly moronic myth that gay role models can corrupt children.
Well, that was a real speech.
One milk really made during a public debate and it bears repeating here.
I was born of heterosexual parents. I was taught by heterosexual,
teaches in a fiercely heterosexual society, television ads and newspaper ads,
fiercely heterosexual, a society that puts down homosexuality.
And why am I a homosexual? If I'm affected by role models,
I should have been a heterosexual.
This simple logical demolition of his opponent's arguments is where we can see
the genius of Harvey milk. Sure. He was bombastic and often angry. Sure.
This anger damaged his home life, ruining several of his relationships,
but it also meant that when America needed someone to be angry,
needed someone who would stand up and fight Harvey milk was ready.
That Selma unfold milk ran his hottest campaign ever against prop six.
He did it with a mix of humor, like when he told her rally,
my name is Harvey milk,
and I'm here to recruit you and impressive political showmanship takes the come
out, come out campaign in fiery speeches,
milk declared the closet was a conspiracy of silence. And that gay people,
we will not win our rights spice stand quietly in our closets.
He told LGBT people, they must come out.
They must show their faces and their family that they existed,
that only they and they alone could dispel the ignorance surrounding their
lives. It was one of the best fought campaigns in California in history.
In real time,
you could watch the polls slide from 61% for prop six in August to
58% against by October, although milk.
Wasn't the only one campaigning against prop six.
It was his efforts more than any others that ensured it went crashing down in
flames. On November the seventh, 1978,
prop six was utterly defeated on the back of this success.
Milk began telling everyone that this was only the beginning that his next move
would be to run for mayor. But sadly,
it never got as chomps by November.
Dan white had become so disgusted with the liberalism of city hall and the low
pay of his supervisor job that he quit in disgust.
But his old police buddies told him not to be done to keep standing up the
family values and law and order. So whites have tried to get his job back.
And man Moscone had refused.
He and milk was certain that's a special election would return someone more
liberal to the seat. And then they'd never have to worry about Dan white again,
but worry is exactly what they should've done on November the 28th white
returned to city hall with a revolver in his pocket.
He avoided the metal detectors by climbing through an open window and then went
to Moscow in his office and shot him four times that done white reloaded.
His revolver walked down the hall to Harvey milk's office and put bullets in
him.
The reaction to Harvey milk's assassination showed both the best and the worst
of America at the truly awful end. There was the trial of Dan Weitz,
which ended in a heterosexual jury, convicting him not of murder,
but of manslaughter in sentencing him to a mere six years.
Whites insultingly dumb defense was that eating too much junk food had made him
temporarily insane in the wake of whites, pitiful sentence,
San Francisco was paralyzed by what became known as the white night riots.
When protestors gathered cops attack them with nightsticks,
sparking a rod that saw city hall partially burned down in retaliation.
A group of rogue cops, drive-ins Castro street and van Lee beat anyone.
They found shouting Andy gay slurs,
as they did say it was one of the lowest moments in San Francisco's history,
cops physically attacking innocent people for the crime of well,
what an illegal level of fabulousness.
But while the white night riots were a stain on California,
what came next was far more inspiring.
The assassination and its aftermath galvanized the gay community.
It was from these ashes that gay activism of the eighties and nineties was born.
And while there would be many,
many more setbacks and marked the moments that the tide finally began to turn
today, gay rights in America have progressed to be on Harvey.
Milk's wildest dreams.
Since 2015 gay marriage has been legal in all 50 States.
There are openly gay lesbian and bisexual people serving in Congress right now,
albeit only nine of them.
Obviously this can't all be laid at the feet of Harvey. Milky was just one man,
one man in a relatively low position in one city who sat in office for less than
a single year.
And yet there's no doubting that he made a difference for millions and millions
of LGBT people. Harvey milk was the man who showed them the way,
the one who showed them what was possible,
what could be achieved if risks were taken as the boy from long islands,
once prophetically said the death threats against him,
if a bullet should enter my brain less than that,
bullet destroy every closet door by living the life he led by
being defiantly out and proud.
Harvey milk helped destroy more closet doors than any number of bullets ever
could. So I really hope you enjoyed that video. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos several times per week, and as always,
thank you for watching.